it was like here with mr. Chris waters
where it packs a checking out all these
goddamn indie games what is going on
everything is coach competitive net is
like cats competitive games just
everywhere you turn man after samurai
Gunn nidhogg star wall all these
incredible games last year it's like
it's on for a couch co co op competitive
and everyone just sort of lasting each
other's faces so we just going to play
some of our favorite ones here first one
up capsule for us right there we lost
our game it was a pretty good fun boo
boo so they described it to me loosely
as like nidhogg with projectiles and so
basically there are two platforms they
run the length of each map or two rails
what each with a platform on it when you
stand on a platform your tech goes your
team's direction when the other team
says I want to go there you try to get
all the way screen screen screen to the
end to grab the capsule and so yeah
basically goalies are gonna be a few you
got a little kind of a bubble shield
thing you can use as well to block a
laser or like bull bump a dude off your
platform exactly capsule and you can
charge a shot which I think Andy was
saying it like slows your drop down so
if you're jumping you can hang midair
charge and like aim where it's going so
again like simple mechanics like that's
pretty much all check out he had shown
we played some yesterday and I've put
playing today then it felt like oh no
I'm get starting to get like the nuance
in this like we should poke it on the
capsule or on the platform because it
moves faster we should like you know
maybe charge up the shot instead of just
popping them off I should be focusing on
taking out the two guys while you focus
on getting the buffer like I gotta use
my shield more I really got these much
you
yeah so like really easy to pick up real
quick and kind of a cool like a pity
Mega Man II aesthetic that looks real
good PlayStation 4 let's see it combat
video game next up go on sport imagine a
future Chris waters where volleyball is
super popular and also shooting weapons
in sports that is the world it's
inevitable that the future will be a
neon dystopia in which we all play gun
volleyball so prepare now by playing gun
sport it's pretty good fun and one
player places like the keeper who is a I
guess sitting back cat move but it's two
shots and then the other player is able
to move around a bit and jump it only
has one shot and you basically are
trying to like score points by getting
this ball into like the goal on the
other side but only using bullets like
three different to your goals that are
worth different points if it it's the
ground you like that's a point for that
but flat the team whose side it didn't
land on that was a super combo tennis
style yeah and every time the ball gets
hit is another point at it so we were
like we were having like 25 point
exchanges and then we had a couple they
were like 15 and that just changes the
moment of them like the game so quickly
and really like like I feel like it
exponentially increases how stressful it
gets when you have a long rally let's go
cuz rallies are usually you know in
tennis for instance are like really
interesting but ultimately it's only for
a point but like the stakes were so high
with those rallies and going back and
forth like we won that game based on
three rallies that happen back-to-back
and also great personal skill and
attractive Indies and I wear a neon and
it's pretty good and that's a that's gun
sports go ahead hopefully PS or Xbox one
and PC later this year next up
baseball football basketball soccer
roller derby ice hockey get it but Danny
why have all when you could have super
slam don't touch down all those games in
one three on three arcanum back to the
days of like ice hockey on the NES
styles just Falls running around and
everyone choosing an athlete from one of
those different sports yes a melange if
you will of all of the various types of
sports available in the real world put
together I like it it's like when I try
and explain where hurling is the Irish
sport of hurling to people I'm like it's
kind of like this board and not score in
this court turns out so is this weird
thing just like all those and you can
score in the soccer net the football
uprights or the basketball hoop but
different players will shoot at
different ones and they could shoot it
one with their normal shot and one with
their charge shot and if you get under
the dunk basketball but hoop anyone can
dunk which leads to these fantastic like
football players going up for this dunk
and the ice hockey player going up
should hit the done you got a timer
right and they just try and get it in
the basket it's trying to dunk a
football yeah come to PC some like fun
competitive sport type action and also
interesting cheering of the way they
like like the goal is worth six the
uprights are worth sorry the goals were
three uprights for dunk five and so you
gotta go for those with high pressure
shots kind of echoes of super mario
strikers charged which is one of the
best soccer games football games ever
made and i really enjoyed like it's just
super dumb fun like there was a streaker
at one stage a game went into overtime
so long but the like ice dude came out
and some Zamboni Zamboni's out of doing
up the the court that the rink cuz like
sometimes it's in the basketball for it
sometimes
it's super fun as soon as they add the
ambulance that streaks onto the field
that knocks all the players over it'll
be perfect next up good night squad uh
like Bomberman but with nights this was
the quintessential past experience
experience where we were just walking
back now ever gonna play and then this
thing was here and it was [ __ ] great
that was real good fun you can get this
on early access right now I didn't
realize yeah it's like a player he plays
a night like top-down bomb on style and
the mode we played was a corruption of
flag variant where you basically you
were all free for all you to get this
chalice and bring it back to its a Grail
Danny their night they only want one
thing the holy chalice and but there was
an eight different game modes there was
like a soccer mode there was free brawl
deathmatch was one kind of a like a
predator tag type thing where one person
was like a big night with a machine gun
and if you killed him you got to be the
night and really good fun really
polished like animation was great it
looks pretty asylum yeah really crisp
colorful so you like had no doubt at all
who you are at any time which when
there's eight players on screen is super
crucial power-ups is sort of like some
you go for but then like one there was
like speed boost she'll definitely want
that then there was one of those bow and
arrow but like this was kind of a twisty
windy corridor place I was like I'm just
gonna not take that one so like one of
them it was like an arena where you have
to like you know it was very evenly
matched for all eight players but then
like a bomb went off and blew up hockey
arena you're like oh way that can happen
like it was I really enjoyed a lot of
gothic about it and not know about this
and so we just wandered past her right
now you also feel bad that you lost to
me but I like the vet oh is that at a
certain stage you got so many captures
and I was like I'm just gonna farm
people because you got five points for
killing people and I got a bonus for a
massive sword so every what everyone
else to shine got the gray I was just
stabbing fools everywhere I may just got
above you and I think you've got like an
extra two kills I got the kill right at
the end cuz yeah I I got that one
captured kept me even with you getting
massive murdering psychopath team
gamespot was first and second so night
squad and heading up next
bro holla bro Oh Chris do you like super
smash brothers but don't own a wii-u yes
I gots the game for you that's pretty
reductive of me I games good fun I
enjoyed that a lot it's a good jumping
off point think of smash comparison but
I you know this has got like it's a much
crisper cleaner feel you know the stages
at least they're not doing crazy stuff
with yet but it's all about sort of and
the items you pick up there's you know
bombs various types but it's all about
the weapon you grab any character has
like two different weapons sort of
fighting styles yeah this customization
for all the different characters but
seems to be mostly on the weapons rather
with smashes mostly that sort of
specific power-ups that that those
characters have yeah and the special
unique character specific supers and
stuff like that so if smet your smash is
a little busy this is like very clean
very easy to pick up feels very looks
very crisp and yeah just too just like a
still like gets to that core experience
of like you're like near the edge trying
to jump your way back someone's trying
to get at you or you like land that
powerful shot and just clear things out
like all those like for pleasures
totally here's clutch moments I almost
like I almost had it won and then dude
like just got it back in the last 10
seconds and there's a you could jump a
lot more I think that's like three
different types of Johnny no and smash
you guys double job and then you got
your be attack they're gonna so it's
like there's an extra one of those so
there's are more sort of battling
happening in the air and it's a it's the
in closed beta at the moment they said
it's gonna be free to play when it comes
out I imagine it probably gonna sell
skins and maps and stuff but skins
galore in this game and they're just
their design theory was sort of like
people from different history and myth
then basically anyone who could kind of
be a badass or skipper Oh Valhalla we're
all broad God got it doesn't those are
our top five competitive games here at
pack so it's been a fun show and I hope
you guys have enjoyed our coverage of
the show so for continuing coverage of
all things packs be themselves prime or
east and make sure you check back to
gamespot com